foreign
grab it
grab it go go
come on come on Mom mom come on
hey there I'm Perry nemrov welcome to RT
Essentials today we're venturing into
uncharted waters to bring you our first
ever scene based episode centered on a
specific filmmaker and speaking of
uncharted waters he actually broke the
record for deepest solo dive in human
history scraping the bottom of the
Mariana Trench in a submersible vessel
but his records extend from the bottom
of the Pacific to the top of the box
office having made two of the top three
highest grossing films ever I am of
course talking about James Cameron
multiple Oscar recipient recipients of
multiple honorary degrees from
prestigious universities he's got a star
on the Hollywood and the Canadian Walk
of Fame yes there is a Canadian Walk of
Fame and there was even a species of
frog named after him to honor his work
promoting environmental awareness Chris
demantis James cameroni a true riveting
fact right there I know he might just be
the king of the world of Cinema but for
such a prolific career Cameron has only
directed nine films one of them being a
short so with that in mind some movies
will feature more than one scene what do
you want me to do the guy likes to take
his time with his movies these right
here are the most iconic James Cameron
scenes I'll be back the Terminator
where's she
look it may take a while I want to wait
there's a bench over there
I'll be back up first is I'll be back
from Cameron's game-changing sci-fi
actioner the Terminator easily one of
the most famous lines in movie history
right up there with I'm going to make
him an offer he can't refuse this line
was so iconic it became Arnold
Schwarzenegger's lifelong catchphrase
and Not only would he go on to use it in
many of his later films but he also
wrote it in wet cement above his
handprints at grumman's Chinese Theater
I'll be back is literally cemented in
Hollywood in Terminator Arnold plays the
titular cyborg assassin sent back in
time to kill Sarah Connor Connor is
being targeted by Skynet a Sinister
artificial intelligence system that
hopes to prevent her from giving birth
to her son John who will one day save
Mankind from Extinction but Sarah isn't
alone a human resistance fighter named
Rhys has also been sent back in time to
protect her Sarah and Reese find
themselves in police custody so Arnold
shows up at the police station sporting
his gargoyle sunglasses stopping at
nothing to get to Sarah the terminator's
power is on Full display as he
single-handedly massacres the entire
police force within the building unfazed
by the heavy gunfire aimed directly at
him
[Music]
ah
foreign
you can sense the fear and helplessness
in Sarah as Terminator closes in but
just before all hope is lost Rhys comes
to the rescue and the two narrowly flee
to safety it's a truly horrifying
sequence one that solidified Arnold's
Terminator as one of the greatest
villains in cinema history Arnold
originally wanted that line to be I will
be back instead noting that it sounded
more like a robot to say I will instead
of all to which Cameron replied with
something along the lines of you don't
teach me how to write and I don't teach
you how to act imagine how different
this scene and potentially the entire
franchise might have been with that one
word change
the Titanic sinks Titanic
[Music]
the Titanic sinks is the climactic scene
from the 1997 disaster film Titanic we
all knew this moment was coming but that
didn't make it any less shocking or
emotional especially considering the
gripping romance that had blossomed
between protagonist Rose and Jack who we
were rooting for since their first
meeting on the ship Stern when Rose
wanted to jump into the ocean but Jack
stopped her like most of Cameron's films
the Titanic pushed the boundaries of
special effects using a blend of CGI and
practical sets to bring us back in time
and all aboard the luxury ocean liner
the crew built a 90 scale replica of the
original ship utilizing private
blueprints supplied by Harlan and wolf
who had built the real thing
oh
wow
[Music]
this 775 foot replica was constructed in
a 17 million gallon tank at a studio
built specifically for this production
in Baja Mexico the massive set could
tilt to various angles with the ship's
rear able to detach and tilt a full 90
degrees for some of the shots in this
sequence additionally several Miniatures
were created for the more complex shots
like when the ship breaks in half and
its Keel and propellers crash down on
all those poor souls in the water below
this was also one of the first films to
ever use motion capture technology for
some of the stunts that would have been
otherwise impossible to achieve these
pioneering techniques combined to give
the historical event the most accurate
and impactful portrayal imaginable it
also won Titanic and Oscar for best
visual effects plus another 10 Oscars
but you know we're not here to brag
highest grossing movie ever at the time
4 four Golden Globes four Grammys made
grown men cried like babies as well
Marine Ambush aliens oh my
God oh my gosh
[Music]
next up Marine ambush from the sci-fi
horror aliens the sequel to Ridley
Scott's alien released in 1979. those
familiar with the franchise will know
just how terrifying a xenomorph can be
basically not the type of creature you
want to be stuck on a spaceship with
Sigourney Weaver's character Ellen
Ripley learned that the hard way in the
first film and the only thing worse than
one xenomorph is a bunch of Xenomorphs
angry ones that don't particularly seem
to care for the human species in this
scene Ripley and a crew of battle
hardened Marines are swarmed by aliens
during an expedition to the Moon Planet
lv-426 the crew and deployed to the
planet to investigate the loss of
communication with a terraforming Colony
only to discover that said colony had
been wiped out by the Xenomorphs with
the only Survivor being a young girl
nicknamed nude a mother-daughter bond
between Ripley and Newt immediately
forms so the stakes are heightened even
more in this shootout as Ripley feels a
duty to protect the young girl at all
all costs
[Music]
in addition to Weaver the film stars
Michael Bean who plays Reese in The
Terminator and Bill Paxton who plays
private Hudson Cameron wrote the
character Hudson specifically for Paxton
and Paxton went through real Marine
training to prepare for the role many of
Hudson's lines were improvised including
his famous game over man quote but
Hudson's real secret weapons were his
powerful f-bombs many of which feature
in this scene in fact the f word was
used 25 times in this movie and 18 of
those times it was used by Hudson
Navi vs humans final battle Avatar
[Applause]
Navi vs humans is the final battle in
the Sci-Fi epic Avatar set on the Lush
alien planet of Pandora the navi are the
indigenous humanoids who inhabit the
land and one such Navi known as natiri
falls in love with a former Marine
turned Avatar named Jake Sully Jake and
a teary fight against the invading human
Colony led by Colonel juarich who hopes
to demoralize the navi population by
destroying their sacred Tree of Souls
which happens to sit Atop A rich deposit
of unobtainium after intense air combat
quarge Escapes in a highly Advanced amp
suit and bases off with Jake on the
ground just as quiet prepares to Slit
Jake's throat Natori fires a series of
arrows that strike quarge in the chest
and ultimately kill him
foreign
s pursue and destroy
[Music]
[Music]
the VFX on display in this one sequence
are just absolutely mind-blowing Cameron
used a hybrid of live action filming and
CGI hiring the effects company wetted
digital co-founded by Peter Jackson Who
at one point employed 900 people just to
work on this one film The Crew developed
Innovative methods for motion and full
performance capture allowing Cameron to
render complex body and facial
expressions in a way no one had ever
done VFX company industrial Light and
Magic founded by George Lucas of course
also teams up with WETA to render many
of the film's specialized vehicles and
CGI explosions specifically during this
battle sequence it's no surprise Avatar
won best visual effects and became the
highest grossing film ever and rumor has
it the film even made George Lucas a
little jealous when he saw it the steel
mill fight Terminator 2 Judgment Day
John you got to go now giant go now
oh
the steel mill fight in Terminator 2
Judgment Day features not just one
Terminator but two set 11 years after
the first Terminator John Connor is now
a kid meaning skynet's original plan of
killing Sarah Connor and preventing her
from having a child failed so what do
they do well they sent another
Terminator back in time to finish the
job but this time it's the T-1000 a
shape-shifting Android made of liquid
metal that can basically ooze his way
into any situation luckily for Sarah and
John Arnold also been sent back from the
future reprogrammed as an ally and sworn
protector of Sarah and John which is how
the t-800 and the T-1000 end up dueling
in this steel mill
foreign
[Music]
it's a bit disconcerting to see the
Unstoppable fear-induced villain from
Terminator 1 beat seemingly overpowered
and outsmarted by an even more menacing
villain but it's a testament to
Cameron's ability to constantly reinvent
and raise the stakes in his storylines
the T-1000 was brilliantly portrayed by
Robert Patrick and a shocking 5 million
dollars was spent just on the special
effects for this character alone
industrial Light and Magic used a
combination of practical effects
light-matching CGI and visual Illusions
to animate and render the complex T1000
and at the time these techniques were
praised for being technological wonders
Tech Noir Fight The Terminator
[Music]
Arnold is back to being the bad guy in
the tech Noir fight from Terminator at
this point in the film Sarah is unaware
of the true reason she is being hunted
down she doesn't know of Skynet or robot
assassins or Reese's role the police
assure Sarah that she'll be safe in the
crowded Club an instructor to hang out
there until they arrive but a room
packed with questionable fashion choices
isn't gonna stop the Terminator from
accomplishing his mission and soon he
tracks Sarah down and attempts to shoot
her this is when Reese intervenes and
rescue Sarah repeatedly firing his
shotgun at the Terminator Point Blank
come with me if you want to live
[Music]
come on
everything about this scene is Iconic
from the characters to the scent
dressing to the music Cameron's ability
to create an atmosphere is unrivaled
even coin the club Tech Noir because
that's how he viewed his film a blend of
sci-fi and film Noir but what really
makes this scene so special is the
rising suspense as the principal
characters all converge on screen for
the first time in this film it sets the
tone for the entire franchise and the
viewer knows in this moment that Sarah's
life will never be the same Bridge Chase
True Lies Bingo good shooting Marines
wow
Cameron and Schwarzenegger joined forces
again for the bridge Chase in True Lies
Arnold plays Harry Tasker a secret spy
masquerading as a doll salesman who
fears his neglected wife Helen played by
Jamie Lee Curtis might be having an
affair but that becomes the least of his
worries when Harry and Helen are
kidnapped by a terrorist group and must
now save the world while also saving
their marriage Jerry is out on which one
is more difficult there these events
culminate in one of the most epic action
sequences ever shot on a bridge and
another classic Arnie line the bridge is
out
the bridge is out
the bridge is out I can't hear you what
happened
for this scene Cameron's team utilized a
mix of Miniatures live action pyro and
CG missiles for the live action elements
the crew filmed at the real seven mile
bridge in the Florida Keys but of course
they didn't blow up the real Bridge so
the engineers at Stetson visual Services
built a 100 meter long replica made
mostly of plaster but the most
impressive shot of this entire sequence
in my opinion at least is when Harry
pulls Helen out of the limo just before
it crashes into the water below leaving
the two dangling from a helicopter as
they escape this sequence was captured
fully in camera with Curtis doing most
of the stunts herself yes she actually
did Dino from a helicopter maybe Curtis
should have played a Terminator at some
point and just saying Ripley vs the
xenomorph Queen aliens
come on
[Music]
[Music]
where there's a high of it there's
probably a queen and aliens build up to
a horrifying reveal and inevitable
battle between Ripley and the xenomorph
Queen but this Queen picked the wrong
human to mess with at this point Ripley
isn't just a Survivor she's a warrior
with a young girl to protect strapped
into an exosuit cargo loader kind of
leaves me feeling bad for the alien
honestly
foreign
wanted this Killer Queen to be
guaranteed to blow your mind anytime so
Cameron and sfx Pioneer Stan Winston
teamed up to build a 14-foot tall
monster made of rubber foam with a pair
of puppeteers stuffed inside to operate
the arms a hydraulic system had to be
installed in the Queen's neck connected
to a steering system for movement with
the face being another separate system
not to mention a crane that offered
extra support for the Queen's body
depending on the shot there were up to
16 people handling this giant beast at
one time and still I think Weaver could
have taken all of them exosuit or not
thanks to scenes like this one aliens
took home the Oscar for best visual
effects
tow truck Chase Terminator 2 Judgment
Day
[Music]
[Music]
our two favorite Terminators face off
again in the tow truck chase scene from
Terminator 2. this time the T-1000
steals a semi-toe truck and chases John
Connor who flees on his Honda motorcycle
weaving in and out of traffic then
through the Los Angeles drainage system
Arnie's close behind on his
Harley-Davidson Fatboy sporting his
iconic leather jacket in Dark Shades who
teaches robots how to dress in the
future fans would probably pay top
dollar to look as cool as Arnold does
here there are so many impressive stunts
in this scene notably Arnold's huge
motorcycle jump which was achieved using
cranes and wires so that stuntman Peter
Kent could fly 85 feet through the air
at 35 miles per hour and not injure
himself
oh
my God
[Music]
audiences were also shocked by the
futuristic CGI used to portray the
T-1000 in all his liquid metal Glory
emerging from the truck explosion
apparently Cameron conceived this entire
scene at the moment he first envisioned
the T-1000 in his mind and since the
original idea for the Terminator came to
him during a fever dream in Rome he
decided to trust his gut or his brain
rather
Jake rides a Banshee Avatar
First Flight seals the bond you cannot
wait
think fly
next up Jake rides a Banshee in Avatar
as we discussed earlier Jake Sully and
atiri have formed a powerful Bond and
The More Time Jake spends with the navi
the more he feels like a part of their
tribe but as we're taught from an early
age you can't just become a part of the
Nabi without first riding a wild Banshee
or as I like to call them beautiful
scary alien pterodactyl thingies natiri
takes Jake to the top of the mountain
where the Banshees nest and guides him
through the difficult task of breaking
one of these creatures similar to how a
cowboy would break a horse Jake
struggles but eventually captures a
banshee and seals a bond when they take
their initially clumsy first flight
foreign
[Music]
Jake earns his place among the navi and
further solidifies his bond with natiri
as the two glide through the air on
Banshee back this scene is just nothing
short of breathtaking Cameron admitted
that this is his favorite moment in the
movie though it proved to be one of the
more complex scenes to shoot due to the
mounted rigs that had to be built for
the actors to ride not sure why they
didn't just use a real Banshee what's a
big deal
the water tentacle the abyss
[Music]
and last up the water technical scene
from The Abyss come on you didn't think
we were gonna skip this one did you the
film follows the search team as they
race to recover an American submarine
that sunk under mysterious circumstances
early in the movie The Crew encounters
strange lights which they label as a
non-terrestrial intelligence AKA an NTI
after a storm hits the NTI forms an
animated water tentacle which they use
to examine and explore the cruise vessel
Michael Bean's character Navy SEAL
Lieutenant coffee becomes agitated and
closes a pressure bulkhead on the
magical entity causing it to retreat but
not before it adorably mimics some of
the crew members faces
foreign
[Music]
hired industrial Light and Magic to
render the computer graphics for what
was informally labeled the water weenie
and cast members had their facial
expressions scan using a software which
then created computer-generated
sculptures that could be composited on
the tentacle for 75 seconds of computer
Graphics it took ilm six months of hard
work I think we can all agree it was
time well spent because not only is the
water weenie one of the funniest
nicknames ever for an alien life form
but this scene also helped earn the
abyss the Oscar for best visual effects
and that wraps up our list of the most
iconic James Cameron scenes as is always
the case we didn't have time to discuss
every noteworthy Cameron moment there
are just far too many to name here but
do not fret we've got plenty of RT
Essentials coming your way so I'm sure
we'll get there eventually thanks again
for tuning in I'm Perry nemra hasta la
vista baby
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]